what do you mean so if we're sold a
story of what men like and it's for men
and the media is for men and we're sold
a story about what men like why is their
body positivity because there's a
certain women i feel like that are going
against that so i think i feel like body
positivity isn't for the women that are
conventionally pretty or beautiful is
for women that are saying you know i'm
not
the kim k's or the whoever out there the
bad bees on instagram i'm a woman and
i'm gonna be put and i'm gonna celebrate
my
my body and who i am right but that's
the story that's the story we're seeing
in the media
so how
but only now not when i'm not when i was
70 to 80 of consumer buying decisions
are made by women everything we see in
the media is marketed towards women yeah
but who's making a decision it's not
women
who makes the decision women do at the
end of the day because women they spend
their money
the decisions come with where the money
is we spoke about the majority of women
want to get married want to be wise want
to be a certain way want to be a certain
thing therefore if they're going to
you're going to create a story about you
just cream and you'll be a better wife
you stick by these shoes you'll be a
better girlfriend you're going to buy
into it you have to take responsibility
for your own actions like again you're
pushing the blame onto something i'm not
pushing their breath i'm not pushing not
because maybe because i
work in the industry where
we sometimes you what you want me to
think a certain way even with podcasts
or whatever people say certain things
get people to think a certain way i'm
not talking about the exception i'm not
talking about exceptions to the rules
about the masses the master told be a
woman be a wife be a mum in order to be
these things buy this stuff but that's
not what we're told with feminism we're
told chase the back i've been told from
a young age chase the bag you can do
whatever you want there's women
empowerment there's not men empowerment
chase
don't do it i mean there's there's
there's i don't know
is there not men i don't know there is
you got that one there
i'm not gonna say anything i'm not gonna
leave it and it's not
and and honestly in society that's not
true if you see anyone shame sex work on
social media what happens the comments
is filled with people saying you're what
slut-shaming
i don't see that on my when i've heard
of wrong blogs but i don't see that
stuff
guys go on tick-tock okay
there's a ton of social conventions that
protect women from a lot of these
for a lot of these things and again like
you said body positivity positivity is
one of many but we're saying basically
because for so long as a woman i mean as
i could say i always speak as a black
woman growing up i didn't see no black
women on tv let alone if it was a black
woman tv it was tyra banks it was
diamond campbell that's all i saw for a
very very long time if i'm not seeing
you didn't watch oprah
no
and it says like secret even and in the
uk it was worse so the uk there was like
i grew up in the 90s
and early 2000s
i'm saying uk so
my mom when i was very young
where are black people on tv where are
where am i so i was very conscious of
that from very young
so it's not seeing not seeing myself my
skin tone my my shape on tv was a lot
for me so now that i'm saying women i
celebrate the way i look because i don't
look i'm not i'm not a 10 out of 10 and
i can take it on the chin i'm good with
that so where i look the size like the
size i am i'm a plumper woman i'm a
bigger woman
i'm a darker woman seeing that now on tv
and being positive has done
me the world of good not because i want
to get a man but i said okay i i i um
and there's more people like me out
there because
coming from a white neighborhood i
didn't think people would like me out
there
but now social media i do see that it's
better for me so just question why does
it matter because i'm i've red hair and
i don't really see tall pale gingers on
tv and i just don't care like what does
it matter if i see someone on tv that
looks like me i feel like it's going to
be quite damaging as well like if you've
been especially for like a lot of people
of color like the shows you've watched
like it's not you're not seeing yourself
and it's something it is sometimes like
maybe younger you would have been nice
just to see like a redhead actually but
oh my god like
it's just it's just a bit more it's not
a big thing
but even like just little things like
you'll see now with the movies they make
and the people they cast you'll see
little children growing up to be just
uplifted by that film and that could
become their comfort film and that
motivation like i'm not does i'm not
ugly because how can i be ugly when a b
and c are on the tv screen right right
but the reason we brought this up is
we're talking about women spending too
much money yeah and so
positivity said that yeah well no
because i i said that because you were
you were sort of saying we spend more
money because of society and so then it
kind of led into body positivity but i'm
saying what does that have to do with
spending like us spending too much money
i just feel like that's our own
decisions and we spend too much money
because we're bad with money not not
because of society oh i don't have bad
with money i don't know yeah because i i
think there's a part of our brain that
like lights up with impulse decisions
that doesn't for men
but do you mean in the sense of we spend
more money because of society because
we're trying to
reach the standard that we think society
expects yeah that's why we spend more
money because yeah no i think we spend
more money because we're bad with money
one of the number one ways that women
are in debt is college debt in the u.s
anyway that's nothing to do and when i'm
having these shoot when i'm having these
conversations i'm talking about the west
so uk and and the us because i'm from
the u.s yeah but i just think women
like every girl i know is bad with money
oh my god oh my god yeah i give my money
to
a girl i'm i'm bad at money yeah i am
bad i am
i'm the kind of person why is that sorry
why um because i grew up poor so now i
have money i want to spend it and i
think i could get when i was when i was
poor simple as that there was time i
couldn't eat so now i can eat i'm going
to buy every eat everything i want
because i can that's my thing i couldn't
buy certain clothes now i can i'm going
to buy it that's why i'm that's why i'm
bad when does that stop for you it's
stopping now because i'm 35 and i've got
to retire soon so for me
i'm not conversation i can't but also
i'm making more money i've never been
before so for me
i can't make it by decisions or my
spending here because i want to get old
one day i want to not have to work hard
anymore that's what i've changed so
that's why i've added money but now i've
got i've got friends that are women
more than men are good man i give them
much hold this for me and say it for me
until i learn to save without touching
money i don't think women are bad
women not about money i mean i know are
better money than men are in my opinion
how can you argue that when the fact is
that most of consumer debt is held by
women
i i'm saying that i'm i'm not arguing
i'm saying i don't think i don't think
many men don't spend but maybe i don't
remember that spending saying that my
plane that i people women that i know
people that i know women are better than
men my mom my aunts they can save money
they can the men will go and try and
flip their money try and so they might
try and become an entrepreneur the
woman's at home counting the pennies
make sure all the bills are paid that's
how i thought i've seen right yeah i
think sometimes in the older generation
that's the thing but with women women my
age are terrible with money they're
always on what's it called sheen
sheen and asos
and like the girls i know they spend
money like it's water
but is that not because of society as
well that they're
like so women
feel like they can't wear an outfit more
than once yes because they'll post a
picture on instagram whatever and so
that's all society-led and therefore
they're constantly buying new things
it's other women it's not for the men
it's other women that shame like what do
you guys care if your girl wears the
same outfit every day
as long
like it's women and women i think it's
because they make poor choices and they
don't have any self-control
like i'm like i don't know
accountability yeah so it's definitely
some women um the women that i i am
around um they they they're not like
that they're very much um good with
money it's more
it's more for me it's the men that i am
around because we make a certain amount
of money
and some men are
crazy crazy stupid with the money um
i'll give you an example
um i remember
uh the first
uh when i moved away so i was playing i
was playing in i was playing in jupiter
premier league and then
the first um the first month we got paid
because they would get paid monthly
whereas in the uk you get paid weekly
the first month we got paid a few a few
days after one of um one of my teammates
came up to me and says um i'm i need
more money and i'm just like what do you
mean you need more money what did you do
with your money he said i just blew i
just blew 6k i'm like
like how what did you do he said women
he went out he so anyways that's that's
his poor decisions um mostly the way the
way i grew up is is it's the women that
that
that are more financially illiterate
yeah
they they the one that that
handle the money they're the one that
that distribute the money and especially
coming
from um i'm originally congolese so
um
the way in our cultural well it's
changing now
but the way the way it used to be the
man will go to work the woman will go to
the market the man will come back home
um he'll put the money on the table
um okay this is the money that i've made
and then the woman would then distribute
like this money is for the rent this
money is for food this money is that in
the oven right well i'm happy that
you're around exceptions but it's not
the rule
women still own the majority of consumer
debt
you've also got to take into account
that you're you're around footballers
yeah who
have a tendency and a reputation not to
spend money well
in terms of how they end up after their
career yeah yeah so so like i can
understand you your point of view where
you find that the men around you are
spending money money frivolously women
are
that men are more likely to pursue high
risk high reward as well so if my
household my dad was the entrepreneur
whilst my mom worked so naturally he's
going to spend a lot more money than my
mom would but at the same time when it's
successful